las urnas salieron de la comisión
electoral bajo escolta policial este
lunes los etíopes están llamados a votar
en las elecciones legislativas y
regionales unos comicios que desde hace
un año han sido aplazados varias veces
debido a la crisis sanitaria y a la
violencia que golpea la región de tigre
tenemos muchas esperanzas en estas
elecciones son muy importantes para la
estabilidad de nuestro país viene para
rezar por la paz y la unidad no hemos
tenido comida durante mucho tiempo
apenas podíamos pagar el pan hemos visto
demasiado sufrimiento causado por la
economía y los problemas de seguridad
queremos un futuro mejor
nombrado en 2018 el primer ministro de
etiopía despertó la esperanza de unidad
en un país donde conviven más de 80
comunidades étnicas sin embargo había
ahmed premio nobel de la paz en 2019
perdió su reputación con el incremento
de la violencia sectaria durante su
mandato hoy el jefe del gobierno quiere
reforzar su legitimidad en las urnas
tenemos delante nuestro la elección
entre la destrucción
desarrollo
quiero llamarlos a unirse a proteger su
país y hacerlo prosperar me diga mi
terry en la cav la chufa legal o debido
a la guerra un quinto de las
circunscripciones no pudieron organizar
la votación por lo que en ciertas
regiones fue pospuesta para el mes de
septiembre en el tigre donde los
enfrentamientos y la hambruna no cesan
no hay fecha fijada las elecciones serán
observadas de cerca por la comunidad
internacional inquieta por la exclusión
de un número tan alto de electores